[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day this is a
special South Park edition where we're
gonna look at some Thanksgiving clips
let's start with this one now big way
children or I have a war to fight
Mustang
[Music]
all the treaty ends now with the
wormhole once again open miles Standish
was able to finally command the pilgrim
armies now attack that left flank good
they're retreating
hit them with the anti Indian device the
pilgrims fought off the Indians making
stuffing once again available on all our
Thanksgiving tables and now you know the
true story behind Thanksgiving stuffing
yeah a gross I said I liked it as a kid
when it was on the stove top that's the
best kind but it's just like a bunch of
bread it's a waste of the plate space
thank you so much
we have two days to prepare I'm gonna be
drinking nothing but water and just like
I'm gonna run everywhere
we ever ever agreed more I agree with
you so much guys this is a waste of
space this is like I didn't know that
this was a real question I thought like
yay like we'd all go yay do some labs
and then we get some stuffing boy yeah
so yummy whatever I feel very strongly
that there's all these ways that people
try to trick you into eating old bread
stuffing is wet bread that's all
biscotti is wet bread or old bread
that's been driving yeah and we just
bread is bread installation no croutons
are the only old bread formulas are what
croutons brought together in a mush of
bread and carbs it's delicious you
should bite your tongue away it's a
waste of space on the plate there's so
many good things that come for things
like green beans you're damn right I
like reading casserole turkey curry
sauce is disgusting oh no I popped that
can I eat it straight out it'll be March
I'll eat that thing
you eat food out of the can because that
is the life you live also stop putting
cranberries in everything what the hell
I'm gonna eat a sandwich I'm gonna have
like cranberries in it are you kidding
me get out get out my sandwich raisins -
yeah raisins are great craisins are
great cranberries are also good wait
what a psychos like watching - why don't
you have a Thanksgiving with you just
wasting space in your plate it's like
cute that you two are trying to do the
other side is better than stuffing I'll
take a bad sweet potato pie over a good
stuffing anything I won't do that peas
are the grossest Kizer not thanks guys
just here's what we've discovered here
Hannah like stuffing cuz her family does
thanksgiving wrong
whoa and on that note which is correct
throw off that next clip Jillian
Oh God we're done for my friends the
time is almost here let us face these
shoppers with the bravery of those mall
security officers before us commander
Marsh there what they're gonna what Tom
we have breaking news from the South
Park Mall in an effort to make sure
everyone is prepared the mall has
decided to push Black Friday by one week
the genius idea was proposed by George
or or Martin who also suggested let's
push Thanksgiving to December 3rd for
pushing the date the mall is now
reducing Black Friday prices to 96% off
to the first hundred people inside the
mall this is gonna be a bloodbath Thom
there will be medical tents ambulances
face-painting no doubt a lot of people
you know and love are going to die Black
Friday just shows America is run by
corporations because that is the true
holiday that's why we have Thanksgiving
it's right I might be a big sucker but
there are some good corporations out
there like REI does a thing where they
it's like hashtag opt outside so they're
closed on Black Friday and they give the
day off to all their employees great for
a hike outside with your family lots of
money one cool thing about REI is that
you can return anything even after you
used it a lot I mean my friends went on
a long road trip when we bought like a
stove top and we cook so much greasy and
the Box got wet and it was smushed and
we pushed it back in the box and it
didn't fit what the counter it was like
oh yeah it didn't work
put the golf club down you crazy you're
overreacting you stupid Swedish cow God
shut up stop would you just listen to me
I'm getting way from you what are you
guys doing check it out
it's EA Sports Tiger Woods PGA Tour 11
for Xbox cliche Thanksgiving like that
no like I'm from Missouri the Midwest
it's just full of people who just like
if you have an emotion what you do is
you just you cram it down so that's what
we have we've got to Asian people mm-hmm
Midwesterners are often said to be the
Asians of America yeah last year my my
dad and I smoked weed because my mom's
cooking is not the best in a state where
it was legal to do so don't wonder like
stuffing a few years ago when before I'm
with my now wife I had when my an
ex-girlfriend was visiting with the
family and it turned into this like a
big blowout fight with like people
crying and screaming home as it was
happening I was like this is funny that
this is happening this is like one of
those jokes from TV shows and movies is
that people getting big family it was
her family everyone nobody was
my family your family yeah and as it was
happening as like huh this is really
going poorly were you involved at all
were you fighting now yeah I was like
playing referee and like trying to
figure out who's what I was sighs I was
supposed to choose and yeah it was
really bad that sounds fun she can't
hang get rid of it he's gone it's time
to embrace the spirit of giving with the
canned food grab come on hurry up
grab a lot son have a happy Thanksgiving
come on boy
now let's see all the goodies you're
going to take home to your family it
looks like you got it I can of string
beans
I like food so much it's crazy I don't
know where I'm going with this
oh you know what you know how like a
story's going bad and you like I found
$20 is how you fix a story I was riding
my bike the other day for real and I've
been braked because I found twice you
just on the street what's the most
amount of money you've ever found in the
ground and I'm gonna one-up your story
by telling you my money is $200 the
street is on 14th Street when you found
I could know it's on 14th Street very
busy street I looked down I was like
wait what and then the guy next to me
saw I like saw pulled out two hundred
two $100 bills and he goes it could have
been him because he wallet no I don't
know loose 120 dollars on the street no
that's boring tell the story Ryan you
got it Thanksgiving anecdote before I
went on a second date to a girl's family
Thanksgiving second date was
Thanksgiving family Wow low reward
situation
honestly it was great really I had
Brussels sprouts for the first time
which made me very farty that was an
exciting personal thing that I was going
through the whole time and I met all
these people I don't remember any of
their names they took a picture with me
and there I was like I don't think this
is a good idea yeah it was why did you
why did you do this that seems great we
had a nice time you had a nice time my
first day yes our first day was on
Halloween do you stay in the fan
my house that night yeah we went to like
Long Island did you do sexy stuff in the
bed I don't remember
next
[Music]